the trouble sort of is continuing for
radical republican congressman madison
cawthorne except it's not really trouble
if there are no consequences and yet
again it seems that's going to be the
case if you're wondering what i'm
talking about i'll explain the entire
thing to you
madison cawthorne uh brought a big knife
to a school board meeting that took
place at a school in north carolina
this is against the law okay a new new
york magazine reporting last week
madison cawthorne the maga congressman
from north carolina
attended a school board meeting in
henderson county where he spoke of
course against mask requirements for
students while he was there an attendee
snapped a photo of what appeared to be a
knife stored underneath his wheelchair
by the following day it was circulating
on social media and the school district
notified authorities and publicly
committed to cooperate with their
investigation in the interest of the
safety of our staff students and members
of the public
bringing a knife onto public school
grounds is a class one misdemeanor in
north carolina but the henderson county
sheriff's office announced the
congressman would not be charged
in a statement the sheriff's office said
that the decision took into account the
full circumstances of the incident by
which i guess they mean a republican
congressman did it quote although
unacceptable although unacceptable
occasionally a person inadvertently
possesses a knife
politics being what it is writes olivia
nutsy kawthhorn's adversaries are not
content to let the issue die with the
ruling from the sheriff's office on
sunday evening american muckrakers a
political action committee that opposes
hawthorne sent a letter to pelosi urging
her to investigate the matter and take
appropriate action the letter includes
further documentation about when and
where cawthorne carries the knife in the
form of a photograph photograph
published in january the image taken by
gabriella demzuk on the morning of
january 6th this hawthorne made his way
to speak to the crowd that would go on
to storm the capital
shows the congressman's fist raised in
the air the letter notes that in the
photo below cawthorne there's an object
bearing a knurled rounded metallic
colored end with a black face a large
hole
and an apparent screw head
bearing a strong resemblance to the
microtech sbd
dagger the idea being that this guy is
carrying knives around
all the time
so remember that madison cawthorne also
tried to bring a gun in his checked
baggage through tsa security at an
airport now
you might say david why are you saying
tried he said he didn't know it was
there
well
it was there not knowing the location of
your firearm is a negligent act
at best
and um he did try to go through with it
in his in his luggage the idea of well
he didn't know that it was there doesn't
really change that and it was just a big
oopsie no big deal no charges it's cool
everybody won't be charged for the gun
at the airport won't be charged for the
knife at school so we're definitely
seeing a little bit of a pattern here
and uh it is against the law in new york
in new york in north carolina it is
unlawful to possess or carry open or
concealed any bowie knife
switch blade dirk dagger or other
pointed or sharp edged instrument on
school property
am i
most concerned with this or is this just
a symptom of the bigger issue
the bigger issue is this guy so acutely
so desperately so obviously has no
business being a lawmaker period he has
nothing substantive or valuable to
contribute about mass mandates he went
with the knife to the school board
meeting just to say we shouldn't have
mass mandates he has nothing relevant to
add about school policy or any policy
whatsoever and kawthorne is really
emblematic an example of the worst of
the trumpian republican party along with
marjorie taylor greene
and lauren beaubert and a few folks who
have been around a little longer matt
gates louis gomer who's been around even
longer and this is why
i see the 2022 midterms as uniquely
important as far as midterms are
concerned you know we said the 2020
presidential election
was likely
one of if not the most important
presidential elections in a really long
time
that was absolutely true
we don't typically say these are the
most important midterms of our time
i am convinced that the 2022 midterms uh
very well may set the direction
of american politics into 24
26 and 28 at minimum
and if these people get reelected
assuming they all run for re-election
marjorie taylor green apparently is we
looked at one of her ads yesterday if
cawthorne runs for reelection if bobert
they may have already filed for
re-election i just haven't checked you
you may know more about it than i do at
this point
if they get re-elected it will be a real
signal
of the likely trumpian direction of the
republican party and thus much of the
country for the foreseeable future and
you know gun and airport
knife at school it's all very very bad
but most importantly cawthorne is a guy
who
offers nothing in terms of policy they
don't even really hide it uh i believe
it was an aide to madison cawthorne a
few months ago said
we're not really running a policy shop
we're running i think they called it a
communications office meaning we're
about social media
and memes and images and bullet points
we're not about policy and that's much
of the republican party at this point in
time one of our sponsors is nebia who
have developed the most impressive
shower head i've ever seen it was
designed by former nasa engineers who
spent years researching how to save
water and what they created the nebia
bimon spa shower uses 45 percent less
water than a traditional shower head but
with an 81 percent more powerful spray
and they do this by using atomized
droplets that rinse soap and shampoo off
faster than any shower head i've ever
used i installed nebia by moan spa
shower in my bathroom at home took five
minutes to set up i've been using it for
about a year
i'm in and out of the shower way faster
because of that powerful spray but again
it's helping the planet and your wallet
by using 45 percent less water than a
traditional shower head nebia is
currently offering free shipping in the
us on pre-order products and for all
other nebia products like the shower
head which starts at just 199 you'll get
10 off when you go to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video